OK, breaking news, right?
It sounds like our activism worked.
Donald Trump's postmaster general, Lewis Dejoy,
will be suspending reforms and initiatives
for the post office until after the November
election.
According to a draft statement that Reuters
is reporting on, great news, right, Dejoy
says, I'm suspending these initiatives until
after the election.
This is being done to avoid even the appearance
of impacting election related mail.
We won, right, guys?
Except not so fast.
Not so fast at all.
This is not what it seems.
This announcement is the post office will
not be changing retail hours.
Existing mail collection boxes will remain
where they are.
No more mail processing facilities will be
closed.
But notice that absent is the answer to the
question.
What happens to what you've already done?
So there's a couple of different things here
that we have to talk about.
First of all, at some surface level, I mean,
okay, good.
Right?
I don't want it.
I don't want to dismiss this as nothing.
The activism, the sounding, the alarm, the
pulling, the joy in to answer questions before
lawmakers, it led to an announcement that
more isn't going to be done.
That's good, I guess.
And and we should recognize that.
But the reality is that the damage may have
already been done.
The changes that they've made already have
been done in disproportionately blue areas
to restrict delivery of mail, to create pileups.
And his statement says nothing about.
We're also going to undo all of the things
we've done in the last three weeks.
It says they will be suspending future changes
until after the election.
So I don't know about you, but I'm not particularly
reassured by this.
He may have already done what needed to be
done in the blue voting areas.
And this could be an announcement, in fact,
to give a false sense of security.
So just remember, these people are not our
friends.
We have no reason to trust them.
He has done a huge amount of damage.
Some sorting machines have been dismantled.
Some collection boxes have been closed.
So the idea that this is a victory of accountability
where we now don't have to worry about this,
we fixed it.
We won, guys.
Now everything's fine with the mail for the
purposes of the upcoming election.
It ignores reality.
And I don't think I'm being too cynical by
saying this, although if you think I am.
Let me know.
The other part of this that really needs to
be restated is that this announcement is not
a license to say I now don't need to worry
and I'll just send my absentee ballot the
day before the election and be confident that
it's going to be counted again.
They are not undoing the damage that they
have already done, as far as we can tell and
as far as has been stated so far.
So if it were me and I am in this position
in the sense that I'm voting absentee and
I will have to make a decision about how and
when I send in my ballot, I would return the
ballot as soon as possible.
If you're mailing it, if you have the ability
to drive it to a ballot box, I would do that
as well.
And that's actually my plan here in Massachusetts.
I will be bringing my ballot to city hall
if I ever get it.
I told the story yesterday of how I actually
still have not received my ballot for the
primary, which is September one.
I requested it at this point.
Something like 13, 14 days ago.
And I would encourage other people to just
make sure you have a plan that makes sense
based on what's happening in your state, based
on where you can drop off ballots in your
state.
And don't make your plan on the basis of a
false sense of security from this announcement.
That's the most important message.
I think they have done a bunch of stuff and
now they're trying to get everybody to forget
about this by saying, hey, you know what?
To avoid the appearance of of maybe affecting
election mail, we're not going to be making
any more changes.
Well, they've already done a bunch of stuff.
We just don't know the full extent of it.
We don't know the full extent of what's been
taken off line.
So we we just can't chance it is the point.
And at the end of the show today, during the
voice mail segment, I am going to be talking
a little.
More about the ballot off situation and how
it really varies from state to state, and
of course, that also makes this complicated,
where a country of 50 states plus D.C. plus
some territories.
And we have 50 different election systems,
essentially with dramatically different rules
in each state in terms of how primaries and
elections are done, where ballots can be dropped
off.
And so much more.
So I'm going to address that a little bit
more later in the program.